el presidente iván duque intenta
controlar un nuevo día de paro con una
nueva jornada de diálogo un día después
de anunciar acceso gratuito a la
educación universitaria técnica y
tecnológica para los sectores más pobres
de la sociedad durante el segundo
semestre de 2021 el mandatario se reunió
con jóvenes para intentar buscar una
salida a la crisis social sin embargo
muchos de los manifestantes no se
sienten representados por quienes están
en la mesa de conversaciones y piden que
sus voces sean escuchadas y es que los
colombianos siguen exigiendo acciones
concretas en contra de la brutalidad
policial así como una serie de políticas
que eliminen la profunda desigualdad
social en el país suramericano que lo
que podemos observar hoy es que lo que
están haciendo es un juego con el pueblo
colombiano el día de mañana va a haber
una reunión con todos los comités de
todos los puntos de la ciudad de
santiago de cali en la cual vamos a
sacar el folleto y la petición que vamos
a hacer al gobierno nacional y estatal
para que el día viernes tengamos una
reunión con el señor duque duque
prometió investigar denuncias de abuso
policial durante los 15 días de marchas
pero sigue sin ser contundente respecto
al accionar de las fuerzas
es injusto
y señalar a todo aquel que se expresa
pacíficamente en las calles
como un vándalo o como un terrorista o
como un criminal eso no es justo no
procede no tiene lugar
como también es injusto
generalizar
el comportamiento de todos los miembros
de la fuerza pública la defensoría del
pueblo informó que 42 personas han
muerto en las dos semanas de paro y que
168 personas están desaparecidas la ong
local temblores registra 40 muertes por
violencia policial y al menos 1956 casos
de violencia física así como 12 casos de
violencia sexual